[Music]
is that fun for you like did you ever
think you would be like dressing little
girls and having fun with it heck no
Thomas Wright is certainly embracing
those life changes right about now hey
I'm so lazy welcome to another edition
of certified country today I am bringing
you guys my complete interview with
superstar and new dad extraordinaire
Thomas Rhett who opened up all about
balancing a red-hot career with
fatherhood and how to look they're doing
it
[Music]
how important is fashion to the business
of Thomas Rath very important I you know
every time I go on stage I'm trying to
you know wear something different or
especially with my merch trying to just
make it I don't know trying to trying to
expand a little bit as far as the merch
code I caught up with TR at his
exclusive fashion pop-up shop in Los
Angeles where he teamed up with Daniel
Patrick made worn New Era and his
personal stylist Kamal Harris to create
one-of-a-kind items for his fans I don't
see any kids offerings here I know we
should have done a onesie way I don't
know what I was thinking but we
definitely need to start making like
onesies and at least like toddler
t-shirts for sure you're already kind of
influencing Willa's fashion with the
sneaker isn't all of that yeah I'm just
drum ruining her already know she every
every time she wakes up the first thing
she says is closet shoes and she goes in
there picks out what she's gonna wear
for the day it's pretty hilarious you're
in trouble dad I am in trouble although
it's bad is that fun for you like did
you ever think you would be like
dressing little girls and having fun
with it
heck no no way my life has changed so
much over the last couple years and
especially this year having two little
girls under two has been a just
life-altering but it's but it's been
super fun and we're so blessed with two
beautiful girls so about what kind of
fashion you gravitate towards really
right now is just street wear and some
have been pretty passionate about for a
while so finish the sentence for me this
look makes me feel relaxed my wife got
me this is my two daughters names right
here so
[Music]
congratulations by the way first number
one album from a country artist this
year yeah it's insane
were you surprised did you kind of see
this one coming I was really surprising
you know I think as an artist anytime
you put a record out you're just like
people like it and so when you see your
record go number one and stay there for
an entire week that was like a huge feat
for me and and just so happy for the
team and the riders and the people that
played on the record because we put a
lot of hard work into into this album so
how did you celebrate when you found out
that the album went number one well I
was on the road I think the coolest part
was being able to have my whole band my
whole crew and my family out there with
us because you know those are the main
ingredients to make it to making a great
record and so it's nice to celebrate the
team I got to know if the girls have a
favorite song I know you said willow
recognizes your voice on the radio she
does yeah yeah whenever she hears like
craving you or unforgettable she says
daddy daddy and it's the sweetest thing
in the world but um my wife's turret
song a sweetheart and we'll the grace
favorite song is a song called leave
right now so they all kinda have their
favorites it's been about a month I
think since I last saw you
has anything changed are you feeling I'm
tireder than I've ever been but but yeah
more tired but um but I think I've
gotten used to it I never in main years
I think before I had kids my biggest
fear was like how am I gonna function
with no sleep but I think it just has
become a new norm and and your days are
just a lot different but they're they're
they're they're packed full of surprises
that's for sure but I did see they
joined you on stage recently yeah they
did my wife hates coming on stage and so
but literally I'm sitting there playing
a song and you know all the people in
the front row were just looking sets
they's really watching they're only
watching the show and they're sitting
there just waving at my wife and I was
like babe you got to come out here well
a great go row dude that girl she's
crazy she like hopped out of Laurens
arms and just started sprinting
backstage and Lauren had to go chase her
down so now tell me a little bit about
what we've got here today like what
should I get what do we have for the
lake oh man what should you get maybe a
flannel yes my stylist Camille made like
three custom flannels and like five
denim jackets that are all one-of-a-kind
all had different lyrics written on them
or you should get maybe the camo it's
real soft like the camo career night
yeah yeah yeah I'll get it for you yeah
wear it with pride
proud TR fan right here I am just here
to show you guys that he did actually
make good on that promise he bought me
this shirt and it is legit probably the
softest thing I've ever felt it's
amazing later on that night
Thomas kicked off the fall leg of his
home team tour with Walker Hayes and Old
Dominion filling out the lineup and it
was such a great show if they're rolling
through your town you are really not
gonna want to miss it I promise you now
as we wrapped up this interview I asked
Thomas to take over this week's song pek
let's see
well I'm biased because my dad wrote
some of these small-town boy Dustin
Lynch is a jam the whole record is
amazing our take on the dance floor John
party that has come up a lot
[Music]
and I could use a lovesong Maren Morris
I just been such a such a huge fan so
those would be my three picks
[Music]